hello everyone and welcome to another
most incredible game i was played in
1973 in tallinn the capital of estonia
and it's uh really an awesome game it
was a really big tournament uh back then
in thailand they organized the big
tournaments every two years and this was
no different many many strong players
we're going to discuss this a little bit
after the game but here mikhail tal
versus boris vasily witzpasky and it's
really really uh
beauty and here spasky is pretty much in
his prime still because in 1972 as you
know he played his wheelchair
championship match against bobby fisher
this is 1973 so he's still uh pretty
pumped from the match and definitely not
an easy opponent you've seen the the
last video we've shown uh okay tell
played a brilliant game but it was not
an opponent of spawsky's caliber uh and
the tal already has uh three big uh
victories uh uh tournament victories
going into this tournament so you know
there are even talks of uh you know even
tal qualifying for for the uh next
candidates tournament and maybe even tal
challenging bobby fischer in 1975 if uh
you know fisher ever decides to defend
his title uh but okay we're gonna
discuss this a little bit more let's uh
check it out it's um
it's it's somewhat complicated but you
guys will enjoy it and this book uh this
uh game is available in thousand book uh
the life of life and games of mikhail
thom that's why we'll be using some of
that zone analysis in this video which
will make it all the more enjoyable you
know you're not you don't have to just
listen to what i'm saying uh so let's
check it out style has the white pieces
and he opens with d4 that's actually not
true
tal actually had the black pieces in
this one so let me just quickly uh shift
that
uh just give me a few seconds you know
if you need to you know
do something that's totally fine all
right that's that's the good stuff
i i would restart the video but i
already said a lot of important stuff so
you know i don't want to just uh
let's check this out here spasky goes
here there we go tile goes here
there we go
all right that was that was very very
nicely done all right now you guys
aren't actually seeing
if anything is happening that's you know
there's a reason for this button now uh
everything is uh good and ready to go so
spasky has the white pieces and he opens
with d4
we have knight to f6 by tal c4 and e6
now now asking what does white want to
play does he want to go for some knight
to f3 action or he wants to go for
knight to c3 uh that means that uh you
know uh he he wants to play some good
chess and that probably means that black
will go for for the nimzo indian defense
here uh and spawsky does in fact go go
for knight to c3 and toss says in his
book that already here he sends the top
that's possibly was feeling very
aggressive this game uh because when he
wants to you know have a nice peaceful
game he just goes knight to f3 and then
maybe he goes into
some sort of a queensy indian defense
setup
or rather against the queen's indian
defense setup so here we have bishop to
b4 tal accepts the challenge he goes for
the nimzo indian defense and bishop the
g5 and uh tal says that here the
gauntlet is thrown down this is the the
very aggressive landing rod variation of
the nimso indian and uh you know
everything just opens up here so here
tal challenges the bishop we have h6 and
now do you go back do you go to f4 do
all the way back to d2 so you're asking
black what do you want to play so here
we have bishop back to h4 and now
striking in the center with c5 and now
spawsky advances the pawn to d5 so
spasky now
says that he's
even more interested in going for some
sharp lines
and towel goes for the absolute sharpest
line with b5 now offers this pawn to
against some activity in the center
and you uh
you know in some older days uh maybe
something like e4 could have been played
but then black has this very active g5
bishop g3 knight captures an e4 uh and
this is now uh you know
very very uh you know crazy stuff bishop
to e5 could be played attacking the the
rook defending the the knight on c3 and
then black and just castle and you know
uh that this has been played before but
here's basket goes for d captures on e6
f captures an e6 and now he grabs the
pawn with c captures on b5 spassky is a
former world champion so if you offer
him a pawn he will he will take that
pawn and now uh in return atal gets this
beautiful mobile center with uh pushing
this pawn to d5
we have e3 now stopping d4 and now uh
tal just castles it's interesting uh why
d4 is impossible because if you just
push d4 it seems like yeah okay you're
winning the knight here but not really
a3 attacking the bishop and you don't
really want to give up this bishop for
nothing so let's say bishop to a5 but
now we play bishop captures an f6 and it
doesn't matter what black recaptures
with if queen captures an f6 we're just
going to deliver this check and after
queen f7 or whatever just queen captures
on c5 and now if
you capture uh the captures on c3 queen
captures on c8 will simply pick up this
bishop so you can't really go for that
you're gonna have to play some like
bishop to b7 but then even e captures on
d4 and this is a complete mess but uh
you know it's perfectly fine
for
uh for white so instead tal just castles
here he wants to you know keep
everything mobile in the in the center
and now knight to f3 uh fighting for
that d4 square you can just allow d4 and
it's hard to say if um
uh if uh
uh spassky knew about this game or
rather of course pasca knew it as he
already had it in 1967 in sochi he had
it against heinz liebert and libert in
that game played knight beat d7 uh but
it's a question if tao knows uh about
this game uh
because he plays queen to a5 and it
seems to be a much more aggressive
attempt than this knight to d7 that was
already attempted against spassky uh and
now uh what do you do just bishop
captures on c3 is the threat and how can
you parry this well uh here just bishop
captures an f6 uh tom mentions in his
book that bishop captures an f6 is kind
of forced because you can't allow knight
to e4 well that's true but it also kind
of isn't uh you you could maybe allow it
but you know
it's completely crazy for example queen
to c2 now you allow knight to e4 to go
really after this c3 square and now
bishop to d3 and now the point is after
knight captures on c3 uh you just castle
but uh you know maybe such such lines
were
weren't known uh back in those days and
now if knight captures on b5 you play a3
you trap the bishop and now uh for
example knight captures on a3 b captures
bishop c3 attacks the rook we're going
to play rook a to c1 and now even c4 is
uh is a possibility where you can't
really move the bishop if you move the
bishop then you have this you know
massive center for example bishop to e2
we're going to bring the bishop to f6
and now uh this past seaport is a
monster so here white would probably
have to just give up
uh give it back the captors were going
to have a capture fest here captures
captures capture so now even knight d7
black can just continue developing
because if you capture here bishop to a6
and both of the rooks around this
diagonal so yeah well it's uh possible i
don't know if if they knew about it you
know it's uh it's it's a very very
tricky line uh but okay here we have
bishop captures on f6 posky just
eliminates one of the attackers and now
rook captures an f6 and queen to d2 and
it is now only as of move 12 the
disposition has never been repeated
again so let's see how tall continues
well top plays a6 he gives spassky
another there he says all right do you
want to keep your king in the center of
the border do you want to play bishop to
e2 and castles as soon as possible
regardless of what happens to your pawn
on b5
but spawsky seems determined to prove
that he can keep the extra pawn and he
plays b captures an a6
so okay let's see what al had in mind
knight to c6 of course this is the theme
of the game we want to execute this d4
movie if we can do that we're on a great
path to victory so spasky plays bishop
to e2
and tal just executes d4 now what do you
do here well e captures on d4 it seems
like you're defending that d for square
more than enough uh but that's only
until you're not so here uh tao plays
rook captures an f3 he eliminates uh the
defender of the d4 pawn
but also in doing so gives up the
exchange so bishop captures on f3 now c
captures on d4 and it looks crazy
because you've given spawsky this long
diagonal but what's happening here what
about the knight and c3 well you can't
really capture if you capture just the
captures on c3 and you can resign there
there's no playing this so sparsky has
to castle here this is his last
opportunity to castle otherwise it's
just game over if you try something like
rook the c1 which seems like it's pretty
sneaky you know captures capture so you
still keep all the tension here but
after bishop captures an a6 this is
again unplayable you're never castling
uh this is the the the bishop fair queen
combo here i mean look at this this is
just crazy so instead after c captures
on the first posse runs for his life he
castles and now only now we have d
captures in c3 b captures and now bishop
captures on c3 attacking the queen and
of course queen to d6 now putting
pressure on the knight and if the knight
moves of course the rook falls and now
what do you play here again if you go
for the rook here on a1 if bishop
captures an a1 then we can play queen
captures on c6 and well there's just uh
not all that much you can do here the
rook is attacked the bishop is attacked
and if you try something like rook the
b8 we're just going to play queen to e8
check even worse king h7 bishop to e4
check and it's game over there's nothing
you can play here captures for example
king h8 queen to h7 checkmate so instead
after queen to d6 uh we have
rook captures on a6 for the moment
defending this knight you could capture
with the bishop and this is exactly what
spassky does uh but you know it's not as
great as it seems so here bishop
captures and c6 was played and it seems
like yes now white is okay but there is
one move that really is problematic for
spassky so feel free to pause the video
here and find this idea for tal while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on not grabbing the
rook on a1 and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is bishop to
b4 yes congratulations to everyone who
found it as i know you guys are thinking
about that b for square all the time
uh and the reason why this is better
than rook captures on a1 is uh how is
the queen defending the bishop here we
can show this of course bishop captures
an a1 but there's a problem queen to e7
and now you you again have to worry
about queen eight check bishop to e4 and
you can't capture on c6 if you capture
on c6 just clean the e8 check and after
the king moves just you know queen
captures here and now uh the bishop on
a1 is attacked and the bishop on c8 is
attacked so you can't go for this so
although bishop captures on a1 is fine
it's not really all that impressive like
i said after queen d7 you're not going
to be able to capture this you're going
to have to play you know something else
but
what queen to f5 can be played but then
queen to c7 and again you're attacking
the this bishop and this bishop and it's
not nothing good for black so instead
tao plays bishop to b4 and now the queen
has to move away from the defense of the
bishop on c6 so queen to b8 is played
and now rook captures on c6 style picks
up the bishop but now rook ate the c1
it's still not as clear what's happening
you can't move the rook because then the
bishop here falls you can't move the uh
bishop as it's pinned so here we have
bishop the c5 blocking uh
this this works attack of course trading
here is out of the question then you
know you're just losing the game so here
it bishop the c5 by tal and now rook the
c2 now spawsky is getting ready to
double up on the c file if he can do
this then he's back in the game but tal
says not so fast queen to a4 now
attacking the rook
and also if you defend the rook by
doubling up we can simply play this
bishop captures an f2 really ugly move
just captures and then of course rook
characters on c2 is completely winning
for tal so after queen to a4 we have
queen to b3 preventing this and also
offering a queen trade but now tell
justin declines the queen trade and
plays queen to f4 uh spawsky again
offers a queen trade with queen to g3
natal says maybe queen to f3 is a bit of
a better offer even though you can
double uh double the pawns but at least
you uh don't allow uh tal's next move so
queen to f5 again putting pressure on
the rook here and again you can't defend
it
or rather you can defend it with rook
after c1 but it's nothing uh nothing
impressive just bishop to b7 and again
uh thal's bishop player is fully
operational here so here we have queen
to f3 again offering the queen trade uh
it's interesting queen to b8 czech
trying to go for that bishop of course
does not work because the queen is very
important here guarding the f2 pawn if
you deliver this checking h7 and queen
captures here again just bishop captures
and f2 is completely winning uh there is
not much you can do here and after let's
say king to h1
you can pick up the bishop of course
then rook captures on c1 so king h1
we're going to play rook captures on c2
and you know white resigns so after
bishop to b7 we have queen to f3 again
offering a queen trade but now queen g5
you can see how much pressure tal is
putting to uh to spawski's king with the
bishop pair and the queen so queen to b3
now again attacking the bishop putting
some pressure on the e6 pawn but not
just rook to c7 defending the bishop and
asking are you maybe interested in that
juicy e6 pawn uh but if you play queen
captures on e6 just rook to f7 blocking
this and now there's so much pressure
here look at this the f2 pawn is
attacked uh checkmate is being
threatened there's just you know
whatever you place something is is is uh
you know uh coming off the board so
after rook to c7 spassky played g3 in
order to you know prevent something but
when uh you know you're staring at the
bishop pair like this you know playing a
move like g3 doesn't help all that much
but there really wasn't anything better
so feel free to pause the video here and
you know win the game for tall while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting any of
the fine moves uh but to those of you
who found the absolute killer move uh
congratulations you are a true master of
uh
you know uh just solving chess games uh
so the movies bishop captures an f2 with
check that's the good stuff now of
course the rook cannot capture our queen
and rook are already
preparing to grab that rook on c1 so
king captures on f2 was played and now
queen to f6 with check and now you can
see that the bishop slicing all the way
here queen slicing through the file
queen being able to jump over to the e
file the rook being able to go over to
f7
is enough to
defeat the white king and tal says that
the queen to f6 is uh
playable and it's winning but queen to
e5 was just much faster as you'll see
but okay he will eventually get that e5
square so king to e1 if you go to g1 it
doesn't help just queen d4 check for
example king f1 and rook to f7 check
kink the e1 queen e4 check and that's it
if rookie 2 queen to h1 check you're
going to play king d2 now rook d7 check
and well now you either start losing
some uh material or if king e3 just
queen f3 is checkmate so after queen to
f6 checks basket goes to e1 but now
queen to e5 check king to f1 and now the
chapter a6 with check king g1 we have
queen to d4 check king to g2 and now
queen to e4 with check king to g1 and
now bishop to b7 uh preparing some
bishop queen to h1 check action but also
if just rook captures in c7 then even
bishop queen to g2 checkmate is is
playable so there's no good move here
for spawsky he plays h4 but now queen to
h1 check king f2 and now rook to f7 with
check we have king to e2 uh sorry uh
king to e2 now comes queen to e4 check
and he was in this position on move 38
that boris possibly resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
the rook controls the entire f file
queen controls this and there's really
nothing you can do here if you try
something like queen to e3 just blocking
this uh there's the bishop to a6 check
and after something like king to d2
there's even rook to d7 check and
there's no way for you to keep defending
uh
the queen here and other than this
there's really uh nothing if if king to
d2 we can again go rook to d7 check and
after king to c3 of course queen to d4
is checkmate so whatever spassky plays
it just runs into checkmate uh so of
course after queen to e4 check he
resigned the game
so uh another very impressive victory by
tal uh against the former world champs
champion boris spassky and like i said
spawsky lost the the title in 1972 this
was played in 1973 so spassky is still
in uh in uh you know in in good form
after people preparing for his world
chess championship match uh but uh you
know just to give you an example of how
strong tal was here these are the final
standings of the uh tournament in
tallinn so you can see tal won the
tournament with 12 out of 15. so that's
nine wins zero losses and six draws uh
and second was pologavsky with a 10 and
a half out of 15 and then you can see a
series of incredible players with nine
out of 15 ballast of david bronstein
paul caris boris pasque uh so you know
just uh a completely elite tournament
where tal just you know
wins the tournament for example three
full points ahead of boris posky that's
pretty crazy and this was uh taw's
fourth win uh fourth big win tournament
in a row uh and you know like i said
there were talks of maybe even tal uh
challenging bobby fischer in 1975 if you
know he continues to do this well and
qualifies for the candidates tournament
uh but in the interior uh this year in
1963 uh he didn't do all that great the
tournament was won by anatoly karpov uh
well it was a shirt first between karpov
and korchnoy uh and tal now you know was
somewhere in the in the middle of the
table uh so uh unfortunately his great
uh uh you know streak of winning
tournaments did not continue all the way
to the interzonal tournament uh but yeah
just another tall game i hope you guys
uh enjoyed this one against the such an
impressive player like like boris vasily
vitzpasky hope you enjoyed that uh and
yeah maybe maybe we can cover some old
games um again now now after covering
two tall games you know it seems like i
might be covering even more but we'll
see you know i don't just want to you
know hand pick the games i i would
really enjoy picking like a tournament i
still haven't uh done that uh you know a
great tournament that i i really wanted
to show you guys i know you guys know
which one i'm talking about david
bronstein wrote a great book on it uh
but maybe yeah maybe something like that
but yeah i hope you guys uh enjoyed this
i would like to thank samuel swanson uh
mr hoody guy michael colbert uh newt eva
scorglund and christophe schmidt for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing uh to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else is happening in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an extra rest of your day